there was a bus full of kids they
started yelling Feeny thing brave one
that I am I've ran around the block just
to hit away from them it was a whole bus
of them
Fanny coming after me
[Music]
I was a sent a script by Michael Jacobs
the producer and I read it I said I
don't want to make fun of a teacher they
need our respect they're underpaid and
they're very important and he said I
don't intend to do that the person in my
mind he said that I'm going to be
writing was a teacher I had in high
school than I thought very much of and
he became a mentor of mine so I have a
great deal of respect for this part I
said okay that's good that's the way it
happened and I'm very glad it did I did
a lot of scenes over the fence I said to
Michael how many scenes am I gonna be
doing over this fence he said hopefully
a lot the fence I'd take the fence and
put it in my backyard
I see rusty William Ross he's a great
guy I saw Danielle just the other day
here she comes in with this big hat and
everything and I look under and I said
is that you Danielle it was great seeing
her she's a lovely lovely lady they're
all grown up now Ben Savage I saw him
because of this Girl Meets World here
that boy a little Ben comes driving up
in a big truck and hicas this young man
out who I hadn't seen for so long he's a
great great young man I was born in
Brooklyn I should basically have a
Brooklyn accent uh certainly a New York
accent but as a child about 15 I got
into a play called life with father the
family in the play were from New England
I picked up that New England accent
without even thinking about it I just
absorbed this from all these people
that's what I wound up with
[Music]
I spoke to the class I said to them
dream try do good boy I was close to
tears frankly it prevents seven seasons
and but that was it and that I will
always remember yes
[Music]
these are difficult times young people
they've got to form an opinion and
they've got to act on it by act on and I
mean they've got a vote when it's chance
to vote and use their own judgments
about what is going on these days your
birthday is tomorrow
do you have a birthday wish yes my wish
is that I have another birthday after
tomorrow yeah
okay okay Wow okay I'm gonna take a wish
[Music]
what it hit it thank you so much okay